malgré tous les efforts du gouvernement
américain dont le recours aux produits
importés de l'étranger une pénurie de
lait maternisé sévit toujours aux
etats-unis
c'est la fermeture à février dernier
pour des raisons de salubrité d'une
usine du plus important fabricant
américain de lait maternisé qui a
aggravé ce problème persistant chez nos
voisins avant la pandémie en moyenne la
demande dépassait de 5% l'offre en lait
maternisé ce chiffre a doublé durant la
pandémie est presque quintuplé
aujourd'hui
partout les stocks sont très bas et
cette pénurie est particulièrement
pénible pour les familles à faibles
revenus qui bénéficient normalement de
lait maternisé offert un très beau prix
la solution du gouvernement byden des
incitatifs pour une augmentation de la
production locale mais surtout un pont
aérien pour approvisionner les etats
unis les deux premiers vols ont ramené
d'europe 1 million et demi de bouteilles
de lait un troisième vol arrivera
bientôt d'australie et d'autres suivront
à l'opposé le canada ne connaît pas de
crise du lait maternisé et sauf
exception des approvisionnements sont
stables il arrive que des gens achètent
davantage
numérique sur une journée souvent
pour l'instant seuls les préparations de
lait maternel hypoallergène sont parfois
en rupture de stock au pays ici normand
grondin radio canada montréal